on parlait du froid il ya quelques
minutes
eh bien le froid hivernal ne fait pas
que je les les cinq grands lacs mais
décourage beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui
s'en vont dans le sud de tellement que
la demande augmenter les prix augmenter
environ de 25 pour ça reportage
nicole jamet bon c'est le goût de partie
la baisse de la canadienne ne semble pas
refroidir les voyageurs québécois on
parle dans ce cas chaque année
mais cette année je vous dirais que en à
bière de partir à cause du froid donc
fait plus froid cette année ça nous
incite plus à partir hier matin j'ai eu
un rendez vous d'une demi heure quand
j'ai raccroché j'avais sept messages
dans ma boîte vocale
donc il ya des journées où ça ne
dérougit vraiment pas nés quand
saint-hilaire travaille depuis sept ans
dans une agence de voyage depuis le
début de l'hiver elle constate une
hausse de 25% des ventes pour les
destinations soleil
c'est la première année qu'on voit une
augmentation aussi importante ayant
peuvent plus y ont froid et exemple à la
relance des clients qui devaient aller
faire du ski
cette semaine m'ont appelé la semaine
dernière et andy y annonce trop fois on
s'en va dans le sud varadero cancun la
saison des destinations soleil a
commencé plus tôt en raison du froid
semble aussi vouloir se prolonger et
même débordé jusqu'à l'été nos voyageurs
vont en profiter pour quitter le québec
jusqu'à la fin avril jusqu'à prépa et
cette année on a trois bouts vols au
départ de québec qui sont déjà
programmés pour les caraïbes
donc ce que je crois qu'il va avoir
comme effet le froid c'est que les gens
vont souhaiter s'évader lauzeral était
aussi là l'engouement des voyageurs pour
le sud se constate également chez scea
québec
ici la hausse a été de 16 % jusqu'à
présent du jamais vu pour angelina nikon
hiatus qui en est à sa 19e année
carrière l'augmentation est vraiment
véritable cette année encore plus que
qu'est ce qu'on a connu dans les années
passent ces ports heures devant que les
gens qui sont partis plus tôt cette
année donc en descend mais aujourd'hui
parce qu'il fait très froid il retourne
pour une deuxième fois donc c'est ce qui
explique un peu de l'augmentation des
chasseurs d'aubaines burt paulin sans
oublier les soldes
malgré une forte pression sur la demande
l'offre plus grande des compagnies
aériennes a permis de limiter nos mains
ce à des prix qui demeure tout de même
plus élevé que par les années passées
ici nicole jamet radio canada québec